[Music]
[Laughter]
that's very appropriate for this level
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is so he can just blended right
here oh my god where is here this is
some crazy fish she needs to be in the
circus
closes I have blown you uh-oh all right
so you're a chair you looked out of
place and I couldn't pick you up
I didn't expect you to die in one hit
all right well I was a fish originally I
just say I discovered that and Wade
studies around I wanted to see if I
could be an orange one I'll just dig
around can't move oh there we go okay I
guess just be easy Jesus and the first
time we played this vet ball there I
couldn't get out of the water so are you
in here now where are you mark I'm
[Laughter]
opposed to damage I think it's under
water cuz all right fine oh is that you
yeah yeah I'm getting some plenty of
watering today won't you afraid your
plant or my roots are being fully
nutritional ice it's not even a word I
don't even know nutri sized new Trisha I
like that wood
what is the actual word there's a word
for that I can't shoot this gun oh yes
we're making that a new word everyone in
the comments use nutri sighs from now on
like after you finish a big meal huh oh
my god wait I just exploded the bananas
and they float where did the bananas and
they float explode you touch anything
they float in the war
what is this glowy stuff over here
[Laughter]
holy crap just so you guys I'm no longer
plans yeah I don't exactly blend in
either but hey you're underwater so
you're out of plant and you are come up
on the glass
no don't the glass base of that
staircase you might see a little
surprise do you want a quiz or [ __ ] that
I just don't got my misery man early
work underwater wait can you even hit
him from there wake up yeah wait where'd
he go oh did you get him I had to throw
up so hard yeah you borrowed him real
good you smacked him around a bit oh my
gosh our turn ladies and ladies yeah
whatever
ladies and ladies no it's great about
this Bob you're stuck with Wade I've
been on the same team I'm so happy you
wanna try to sing the song as a song
yeah yeah but now you know it so sing
along everybody in the comments scary
when you're a fish like come on where
you go
[Laughter]
while you're down there Wade you wanna
take care of some things for me you seem
to be stuck so I'm just saying well oh
no oh no we're still here he's still
alive or was barely going underwater is
the perfect way to become invincible oh
do you have 65 but I was glitched at 17
okay all right gotcha
all right we're gonna figure this one
out no probably all right
probably whoa
everyone do their best Lola Lola face oh
wait god no stop it every video Wow hey
what was that yeah won't let me shoot
underwater wait why don't we pull faces
every video people like that oh is this
where you got that shark it's just
sitting here I know exactly where is he
where is a box and he's smashing
everything else by me I got this one
husky I just think this from bobs
perspective it's so crazy you gotta lose
me
[Laughter]
damnit take it away is my favorite how
the underwater stuff works I think Oh
stupid stuff
the shark is when you go in the water
you have to like turn behind you and
there's like a little like opening you
only get two from underwater
and the Sharks just like sitting in the
corner yeah that's weird though it with
the where it was it was just like
looking at me and that's my worst fear
like going into a pool and just
imagining like below the surface I'm
your biggest fear no way yes yeah like
if I was like in the morning and I heard
a loud bump last thing I god you guys
are shooting each other what are you
doing pistol pistol I wanna know amok is
Oh
blendin do I cuz I can only see
blackness Oh what yes I am underwater
really yes I am
why would you be my pool John the
water's warm here in this one spot
around me it's plenty of room I see
boxes floating up I see the my
perspective is so urgent I think I see
things popping in and out of the world
at random it's very strange box like if
someone was 2 feet in front of my face I
wouldn't see him I'm glitched I'm stuck
where oh ok ok ok
Wow thank you Bob just came to like beat
my face of the crowbar who the heck are
you mark all these lovely fish in here
look lovely
there's fish everywhere what's my
particular there's a lot of them we
should play the guessing game how many
fish are next to mock right now
one two oh no you have this random and
then we give a price to the guy who's
closest I win I say 52 here we go
I don't understand oh come on
this aquarium that I'm in really is my
scientific interest looking good there
I don't understand how can you get weary
I see you goodbye Oh a simple oh no no
it's only chicken though where'd you go
oh I'm just gonna stand by the door I'm
not gonna stand for this is how you swim
to join not actually being in here
Oh your ex Oh God quick listen to the
fish mark win wow I'm out of underwater
ammo for three seconds can you kill me
in that time mo that works underwater
how to kill in the one stick gonna kill
me with a stun stick God you don't have
a crowbar
oh you know I don't know I've got 63
hells they've hit me what he'll come on
[Laughter]
hit me win my favorite moral that server
that was the best I'm gonna do that one
again
yeah
[Music]